I was playing with Chachi PT and I put
in the opening scene of our movie didn't
tell the studio I was doing this I put
in the openings a few pages then I said
can you please tell me what happens next
oh no and it said I think four possible
things happen next and one of them was
spot on and I stopped
yeah I was like okay this is getting a
bit too interesting now how's it going
there citizens of the reject Nation it's
your boy Donald out here flying solo
today in these Cinema streets quite
literally I tried to shoot this walking
right out of the theater and the
security guard there said nope but you
can shoot it by your car so I set up a
pretty decent shot by the car only to
get alley-ooped by a different security
guard instead it's time to go and so uh
we're we're Kicking It Old School to
talk about the Creator the new Sci-Fi
Action epic co-written and directed by
Gareth Edwards who you may recall as the
Director of Rogue one a Star Wars story
Godzilla 2014 and a terrific Little
Indie sci-fi flick from 2010 called
Monster check it out if you haven't
leave a like on this video in fact leave
a like for original sci-fi that's what
we're going to be talking about today
and speaking of talking I am actually
going to be lucky enough to be able to
speak with director Gareth Edwards a
couple days from when this is being
recorded So what's gonna happen is
actually I'm going to give you my
initial thoughts here fresh out the
theater as the movie is washing over me
and then we're going to go into the
interview see what the director himself
has to say about the you know process of
bringing this all to life and maybe see
if any of what I got out of this is
anyway related to what he had in mind
anyway what is the creator about and how
is the movie decades into the future our
worst fears have come to pass and now a
war rages between humans and robots with
artificial intelligence and amid that a
former Soldier John David Washington is
tasked with hunting down the ai's newly
developed super weapon only to discover
that it is a robot in the form of a
young girl and I am almost I'm kind of
at a loss for where to begin this is a
whole lot of a movie I made some notes
here just to keep myself on track I
promise I'm not ignoring you because
yeah this movie can certainly be
overwhelming at points although not in a
way I would necessarily say is bad just
here in this moment I find myself very
much appreciating and admiring just the
things the movie was going for and quite
often succeeding at in front of and
behind the camera there's tons of great
work and movie Magic on display I'm just
kind of touched by its overall sense of
heart that was a particularly nice
surprise especially as represented in
the relationship between its two Central
characters Joshua and Alfie John David
Washington and Madeline univoyles when
those two are together on screen it is
the heart and soul they play off each
other really naturally and I think her
performance in particular as this you
know supposed super weapon is just
pitched so gracefully you know I
believed her as a self-aware robot I
believed hers just an actual kid she
choked me up she made me laugh you know
like I can't really overstate how
striking her performance is and it's to
the director's credit also because this
is a juggling Act of a very high order
this feels like it's attempting to be a
bit of every kind of sci-fi movie all at
once part sprawling action epic part
intimate character piece part cyberpunk
rumination on things like Evolution and
the nature of Consciousness and Free
Will and the mess of all those things
the interplay between humanity and
Machinery empathy Etc and it
demonstrates the chops to be able to be
all of those things and then some though
it does sort of feel like they were
forced to maybe prioritize certain
aspects over others in the editing room
with that there are ways in which the
film's reach can outweigh its grasp at
times or it can maybe feel a bit crammed
I could see some people really loving
this I can see other people maybe coming
out a bit frustrated by some of the
potential that feels maybe a little less
developed or explored or perhaps pared
down in favor of a more agreeable
runtime slash MPAA rating in order to
attract the kind of audience this needs
to in order to make its budget back it
does feel a bit at odds with itself in
that respect release the Edwards Cuts
but this to me does feel like a
culmination of each of his features up
till this point Godzilla and Rogue one
certainly but very much monsters as well
in the way that it really feels like
you're out on the road in the thick of
things experiencing this world firsthand
you know monsters does it with Mexico
and here you have you know like Thailand
and various other Eastern countries you
know kind of all over the globe and the
Creator's future is really gorgeously
shot and lived in the blending of
locations and designs and makeups and
models and physical and visual effects
costumes it's all impressively realized
and effectively transported solid Han
Zimmer score as well and some pretty fun
needle drops I wasn't expecting this
also reminded me of monsters and that it
clearly wanted to incorporate a more
intimate and off the cuff approach to
character development which is
definitely present here and exhilarating
in fits and bursts although it does feel
like a certain amount of that maybe was
paired down to The Cutting Room floor
this has one of those broadcasts kind of
like you'd see in an alien type movie
where it's people from across the
Spectrum and they're all doing good work
but it can leave you craving a bit more
when you have people like Gemma Chan or
Allison Janny playing against type as a
sort of gruff Commanding Officer Ken
Watanabe Sturgill Simpson Ralph innocent
you really want to be able to soak up
that Ensemble and I think certain roles
can feel a bit slight or pared down at
times Blade Runner definitely feels like
an inspiration for this I was reminded
of Neil blomkamp kind of across that
District 9 chappie Elysium run also Leon
the Professional some iRobot tenant if
you want to talk about her archetypical
protagonist various Vietnam war movies
Avatar and I haven't seen it but I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say that
there's some children of men in here as
well uh if you like any of those movies
chances are you'll get something out of
this this also feels like a really cool
video game at times so yeah a thick
review for a thick movie but I am very
happy to see original sci-fi on this
scale again with as much Vigor as this
has swinging for the fences as
passionately as this is really gave me
some things to chew on multiple angles
to look at it from and I think that's
part of what good Sci-Fi is supposed to
do along with transporting you and all
that good stuff it definitely felt to me
like Gareth Edwards and his team really
took this opportunity and went for it
and I will always take a film that's
trying to do a whole lot over not much
your enjoyment will depend on which of
the films inside of the Creator you most
gravitate toward personally but either
way I think if you're a Sci-Fi fan this
is definitely worth checking out and
forming your own opinion of but enough
of my opinion Let's uh let's see what
the man himself has to say
Gareth it's it's a huge honor to be
talking to you right now I've been a fan
of you know monsters and Godzilla and
and Rogue one up until this point and
and just I don't know to to be here
right now and is a big fan of sci-fi
this is super cool so thank you for
taking the time out no thanks for having
me thank you yeah absolutely um and I
mean this this movie watching this kind
of felt like a culminative experience
just based on you know those other
things that you've done you know it
brought in some of that you know
character intimacy that a monster's
maybe has but all that scope of the
others were you thinking about any of
that you know during the production and
you know bringing all this stuff to life
or were you more about just pushing
ahead and you know figuring out what the
next set of influences and Inspirations
would be no thousand percent it was it
was like you know you grew up wanting to
be a filmmaker right you're trying to
get into what you think you're trying to
get into Hollywood and then what happens
is your only way in is to make a film
and typically everyone's first film they
have to make for no money yeah and then
the weird thing happens which is you
make a film for no money and it's
actually a great experience like sure
you have all this freedom and all this
control and then if you're very lucky
like me like I kind of won the lottery
and I got to do like these big Hollywood
films and there's amazing things to
doing that by by a mile like you know
you get this massive canvas you get big
theatrical releases you can kind of do
anything you want but there's things
that you did when you had no money that
was super easy that now you can hardly
even do when you've got like a massive
crew and millions and millions of
dollars it's like it's basically
whatever is easy and hard with one you
swap them over for the other okay and so
so I spent a lot of time after Star Wars
going how do you try and get both of
these to like how did you get all the
positives of no money in an independent
film and all the positives of a giant
Blockbuster and how do you make a film
that includes both and so this whole
thing was an exercise in doing things
differently trying to reinvent the wheel
and and because the new technology and
new camera equipment uh we kind of
instead of doing everything against
Green Screen green we went to eight
different countries around the world we
went to like you know the Himalayas and
volcanoes in Indonesia and uh Tokyo and
Thailand Cambodia and and shot this
movie we went 10 traveled 10 000 miles
80 different locations blah blah blah
blah yeah and then feel those places
yeah because this when some people talk
about World building and go how did you
make a world realistic whatever like the
big trick is go to the world right like
that it's already there like all the
crazy random chaotic details they're all
there just go shoot the world and then
add in the science fiction and it feels
so much better and and so you know kind
of tried to do that yeah absolutely and
I mean this has that aspect of you know
there's the tension of everyone's racing
kind of towards the central point and
you have you know the sort of Road movie
unfolding and at the center of all of
that is this intimately developing story
between Joshua the John David Washington
character and and Alfie and I gotta ask
you know how how working with both John
David and Madeline univoyles like that
performance you know kind of blew me
away because I'm like you know this this
kid is so real and endearing and yet I'm
also like crying and stuff like how did
you go about building both the chemistry
between them and that growth but also
working with her in particular and
building that performance because it's
very striking it was I think we both
knew me and John David both kind of
understood that the most important thing
that could happen on set was that he
bonded with Madeleine and Madeleine is
like Way Beyond her years
um she is like reincarnated adult or
something like I don't quite understand
how she's such a great actress so young
and so as a result it takes a lot to
become Madeline's friend like you you
she won't let you in easily right she's
very you know keeps herself to herself
she's very shy and and so we tried
really hard for for John David to become
close friends with her and God bless him
he got in there somehow and they became
Inseparable yeah and it was kind of
hilarious to watch because we do takes
and the second the take was over you
know actors you know like they do they
they go off to the corner they go trying
to stay in the zone you know if it's an
emotional scene or something they're
just trying to just stay like as people
are moving lights whatever's going on
and madelina go up to him and hold his
hand and just like talk about her toy or
something you know and he's like oh
really you know he's like being really
nice to her and everything like like a
big brother or something and I'm like oh
poor John David but it really helped
yeah it really helped make their Dynamic
on screen they were inseparable and we
actually it was Madeleine's birthday
just a few days ago and some David and
her family we went to Disneyland and it
was so cool and again they were just the
whole time it was just like being back
on set like she was beaming it's a very
high stakes Disneyland trip then yeah
yeah yeah it was like it was a mini
version of the Creator like you gotta
get her to Galaxy's Edge right away yeah
we did go there actually yeah I believe
it no and I mean you know this is an
interesting kind of moment to be
releasing a film like this and I have to
imagine that you've been you know
working on it and building it for a long
time but now we're in this moment where
AI is like the Forefront of the cultural
conversation and granted it's a
different iteration but you know does
that have any sort of resonance with you
does this feel like wow we couldn't have
lucked out with a better moment for this
or is it kind of arbitrary no no we
totally looked out thankfully the
robopocalypse is I think scheduled for
November sure so we've we've got a good
month of uh at this theatrical release
until like they take over the world yeah
so so we got lucky but no it was when we
when I was kind of come out with this it
was a distant dream it was like flying
cars or living on the moon which wasn't
supposed to be happening right now and
so it's very surreal I even actually I I
was playing with chat GPT and I put in
the opening scene of our movie like I
gave it this I didn't tell the studio I
was doing this but I put in the openings
a few pages the first scene and then I
said can you please tell me what happens
next oh no and it said I think four
possible things happen next and one of
them was spot on
and it was like it was quite shocking
and it was like okay all right and I
stopped I stopped into the shiver yeah I
was like okay this is getting a bit too
interesting now yeah I believe it well I
mean our our time has come to an end I'm
sad to say I have a million questions I
would love to ask you but again I really
appreciate you taking the time and it's
again really cool to see a movie on this
scale that does seem authentically
concerned with being both you know a
touching character piece with you know
ideas and also something action-packed
and thrilling in scopic and all that
stuff so uh so I'm inspired and uh yeah
I really appreciate you for chatting
with me today thanks man thank you thank
you so much yeah looking forward to
whatever's next Cheers Cheers appreciate
you
thank you